well reject nation looks like we got a
little
teaser here for the flash 2022 film they
unveiled the logo but i
personally was like i want to watch
chris's 3c films video
i love chris as a matter of fact i was
messaging chris uh
earlier this week about uh doing a
collab for some time next week
so keep a lookout for that if we're able
to successfully pull it as a matter of
fact i i haven't messaged him back in
the last 24 hours i should do that right
now yeah i'll get it
right so it has to happen now people can
comment harass the both of us
sounds great man about to watch your
flash video
okay
oh damn it i'm out of toilet paper again
[Laughter]
hey guys thanks for watching on this
video holy [ __ ] that was
brilliant
[Laughter]
actual video i have so many questions
about how did you whip that up
with your butt this thing just came out
and he just made this
intro or were you holding on to this for
just the right
thing i was like you look so tiny in
that bathroom it's a luxury
that is a hilarious ass intro dude that
was so funny that was
that was okay
[Laughter]
what is this intro hey guys thanks for
watching on this video my name is chris
it is a crazy day for comic book fans
everywhere because we are just getting
all the releases of marketing
for all these upcoming superhero movies
we just had the trailer
i went ahead and did a trailer breakdown
on that where i explained the world
easter eggs and stuff you might have
missed in the trailer
holy [ __ ] that intro man
with a tiny little teaser that shows the
logo even into the music
that josh reading cuts flash movie
finally signifying
that this thing is actually shooting and
it's coming to us
very it's
the sound of the music and your overall
excitement for the flash
my opinion has definitely changed on
ezra miller's flash ever since zack
snyder's justice league and now i'm just
even more hyped to see this movie so by
starting off let me just go ahead and
show you the actual little teaser
trailer that they went ahead and
released
[Music]
nope it's not it's not blue the flash
logo's not blue wow that right there
but his lighting and then it goes blue
i thought you're making a joke that's
true look at this logo on how the dc is
cool
just keeping the thing of adding the
word the in front of everything making
it just seem
like that's the way to go the batman the
flash
the suicide squad the 3c films
[Laughter]
might actually be our first to the
costume in action this could actually be
the chess piece for ezra miller's the
flash most likely yeah we are said to
get
a whole new costume in this version of
the flash
does it look that much different from
the cw version though
it's pretty similar right
look at that if you were to show me this
i would just think it's the next season
of the flash to be honest yeah they got
an upgraded logo
yeah i mean it's exciting i'm excited
that they're actually good doing it
you know for them after like 10 [ __ ]
years
we'll see if it actually makes it
through production i was really getting
used to the zack snyder version but with
merchandising
of course they're gonna change it up
here it looks like to be getting a
little bit more highlights and glowing
yellow whenever the flash
goes ahead and moves around also that's
the other thing to notice
the flash has been particularly known to
have blue lightning whenever he's going
ahead and doing his motions that's kind
of one of the things
that annoyed me about the flash is just
that he leaves this huge
energy discharge of blue lightning
wherever he goes even if it's for a
small little movement across the room
i'm like doesn't that take away the
whole factor from being one of the
fastest people alive that
everybody knows you just went super fast
because lightning just screwed up this
whole place
they might be changing that and making
the lightning more yellow as accustomed
to the flash instead
of blue like we were getting with zack
snyder's justice league i am really
liking the texture though and the way
this is made i wonder if they're gonna
go ahead and incorporate that whole
thing
that the flash's costume comes out of
his ring like it does in the comments oh
yeah that's right the show got there
like season five or something
i love the scene in zack snyder's
justice league where everything is
frozen in time it's basically
the best scene we've ever gotten of the
flash it kind of has that same
resemblance and i'm happy
that it's got the facing here because
that scene just gives me chills and i
watch it almost every other week
every other week so you've seen it like
five times a couple times
static head shotgun
i like this music a little bit more now
that the flash is actually filming we
can expect to see a lot more stuff heck
we might even get
some reveal photos hopefully they
finally announce if michael keaton's
batman is actually going to be part of
this movie
at the concept man michael keaton's
batman is playing barry
of the 1989 batmobile kind of hinting
that we will be seeing
that version of the batmobile in the
flash movie because remember this film
deals with barry allen
traveling into the multiverse i feel
like you
there's two ways you could do it because
michael keaton gave that interview
recently which is throwing a lot of
people off wait is he not actually
signed on to the flash is that what's
happening here i do
think though that even if michael keaton
doesn't sign on you could use his
likeness if you just put someone in the
batman suit
of course you know you could do a deep
fake or you could do all kinds of things
i mean i don't know if you'd still have
to pay michael keaton if you did the
deep fake
but yeah if you were referencing if you
were like no this version is the one
from the 89 batman movie you could just
put someone else in that suit yeah if
you don't want to see bruce wayne
specifically because even this concept
art doesn't have michael keaton
it just has the batman in the 89 batman
suit yeah you can get
almost like a voice alike and obscure
the face and shadows or yeah just keep
it under the cowl and
pass it right off not be as cool
if you don't have michael keaton in it
though that version of the batmobile in
the flash movie because remember
this film deals with barry allen
traveling into the multiverse
meeting different dc characters batman
you'll also have
ben affleck's batman in the movie and of
course
latina supergirl but it's like i was
telling you guys were my opinions you
know andrew miller's the flash has
really changed ever since watching zack
snyder's justice league there was
a little things here and there that
still bothered me about his character
like him
just being this bumbling idiot when i
think there's more charm to him
than just being the goofball and i think
that's what we're gonna be seeing some
big differences in the character in the
same way
james wan kind of reinvented the
character of aquaman where i didn't like
aquaman in the first justice league
movie but then watching him
in aquaman i liked him a whole lot more
that type of stuff is going to be
happening here
with us just quick quickly
my favorite interpretation of aquaman is
actually zack snyder's justice league
yeah that was my favorite live-action
version we've got in nevada absolutely
you know
you don't watch that the other thing i
am worried about though is that i want
this to feel like a flash movie i still
think it's kind of crazy how the first
movie out the gate
is gonna be the flashpoint paradox story
and it's gonna be a whole different
version where it's not just him
time traveling and messing up his
timeline but jumping to the multiverse
where we're going to meet
so many different dc characters that i
still want this to feel like a
flash-centric
story that i also don't want them to
start so big that
if they do a sequel what can you do
after multiverse jumping
and having multiple batman in your movie
i thought
although you know spider-man into the
spider verse was
miles morales first movie some people
have that similar concern when you're
getting your first led
miles morales movie but even though it
was a multiverse movie of the spider-man
it still felt like this is miles morales
movie
he's still your protagonist yeah that
weirdly it's that movie that gives me
faith that they can do that with flash
i thought this first look teaser was
pretty awesome i can't wait for the
movie but i want to hear from you guys
what did you think of this first look
teaser does it hype you up for the movie
what's one of the first things you want
to see reveal i'm hoping that they
somehow
bring back cyborg into this movie
because i know they cut him out of it
but
i would love it if he comes back in i
don't think that's gonna happen
take care buddy wow okay intro is the
best part of this video
everybody send chris some toilet paper
and he did have some good information
and i feel like there's got to be a
video of chris reacting to ray fisher
information
i'm just kidding he knows let's go he
knows that
i don't think that's gonna happen man
tomorrow chris is gonna have a whole
other video about guys have you heard
about this ray fisher
yeah like what apparently he's got all
this beef with wb and josh
i don't think he's gonna be in the flash
at all wow weird all right guys well
that was a good video
thank you chris for putting that
together man bam that intro that was my
probably probably my favorite one i
don't
know
ass point green light that movie that's
great i bet all the comments are about
your intro
that was great anyway guys subscribe hit
that like button last but not least
jean jeter jean my friend
now gene if there's anyone here that
could create the coolest multiverse at
our patreon page
it's you he has photographed so many
gorgeous
human beings so many beautiful people
and i'm just waiting for the day
where you unite all these beautiful
people
together in one epic photo shoot
can you imagine you would become
so unprofessional that day you could
not resist i know you're a pro you treat
all your male and female models with a
ton of respect
i do think though that you would be
pushed to the edge
and then you would have to go back
reverse time to prevent yourself from
getting sued i'm just saying man i'm
just saying the best use of your powers
is to go back and absolve yourself of
bad decisions
run fast gene run fast run fast run g
run chain save one life
you don't touch